và chúng ta sẽ gửi lắp lốc ngày mấy chiến thẳng tảm,
các người tổng thống mi đúng năng trăm và đợi mũ của ông trong hộ nghỉ thượng định Alaskar hội tổn chó
cho rằng kế mi muốn đạt được một dại pháp hòa bị lâu dài và miến vũn trộ quay nà.
Ông lắp lốc nhận định bầu không khí tại của gặp dưỡng của tiên bóng trăm,
rất tốt và nhìn mạnh Mỹ thể hiện thái độ xây dự tập trung vào cái quả thích cực.
Ngược lại, ông lắp lốc chỉ chết các lãnh đạo cho ông về cách tiếp cận vào nếu quay nà
tại hộ nghỉ thượng định em mới tạm tháng tạm vừa qua tại nhà trắng.
Các liên đạo cho ông chỉ nhận mạnh yêu cầu nếu bắn dựa đục cùng các lực phía trong bài nà.
Thay bì điểm giải pháp sản diện.
Hoài ra phía ngà cũng không đúng tình bởi những ý kiến trên khai của nội nà tốt để bảo vệ u quay nà.
Nhận sát của ông lắp lốc làm nội bật sự khác biệt chiến lược,
giữa Mỹ và cho ông trong việc thuốc đầy hòa bị u quay nà.
Trong khi Washington tập trung vào đảm phản tổng thệ và an người lâu dài,
cho ông vật UTN tập hiện kháp tạm thời những người bắn nông thời ruy trì về cho con xử cho kia.